[Musique]
depuis plusieurs années c'est la mode à
la télévision de relancer d'anciens
formats une famille en or apprendre ou à
laisser et plus récemment la Star
Academy c'est que tout a commencé
à mission fait des records d'audience et
ont marqué toute une génération le
retour à l'écran n'est pas toujours
synonyme de succès c'est le cas par
exemple de Qui veut gagner des millions
qui avant d'être présenté par Camille
Combal a été animé pendant 10 ans par
l'emblématique Jean-Pierre Foucault ce
que c'est votre dernier mot une émission
qui a fait son retour en 2019 mais qui a
perdu de sa superbe et surtout de ses
gains il y a une pyramide des gars cette
pyramide des gars elle a un petit peu
évolué on l'a là ici avec nous
300000 euros si on aurait dû renommer
l'émission Qui veut gagner des milliers
elle n'est pas la seule émission à avoir
signé un échec lors de son retour même
chose pour Masterchef le programme
culinaire de TF1 qui est revenu cet été
sur France 2 bienvenue dans l'atelier
c'est le grand retour de ce rendez-vous
incontournable avec une audience moyenne
d'un million 400000 téléspectateurs le
moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que
l'émission n'a pas fait recette des
amateurs c'est agaçant certaines
émissions sont trop le réchauffer ne
parviennent pas à convaincre les
téléspectateurs pourtant d'anciens
formats à vivre la nostalgie de certains
c'est le cas de yak la vérité qui compte
rediffusé depuis la rentrée sur C8 qui
enregistre des records d'audience et à
glaneretti qui compte nos plus belles
histoires ça commence maintenant la
méthode Coué le Biggie Secret Story de
nombreuses chaînes télé pensent
aujourd'hui au retour de ses émissions
cultes mais selon vous la nostalgie à la
télé est-elle une bonne idée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
35 ans de France 3 c'est pas mal et puis
le meilleur je vois pas qui qui est le
plus connu aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
c'est ça quand même il y a eu midi
comment il s'appelle midi
magazine midi chez vous 12h30 et midi
première
il y a eu midi dernière
Gilbert là ils sont derrière elle se
marre dès qu'elles entendent la voix de
Daniel c'est incroyable la voix de
Daniel Gilbert et Daniel elle a fait la
voix
elle est reconnaissable
vous aimeriez revenir à la télé la
mienne vous aimeriez revenir à la
télévision ben là j'en fais en Belgique
non on m'a proposé des choses un peu
scénarisés où j'interviews des invités
deux invités à chaque fois un français
un bel oui mais tout arrive et moi il y
a pas grand chose qui m'arrive de normal
ah d'accord alors j'ai dépassé la date
de péremption et ben je suis toujours là
alors Daniel oui parce qu'on est plus
près de Saint-Pierre que Saint-Tropez
[Applaudissements]
et vous quand même moi bien sûr mais
vous quand même parce que quel
personnage
quand est-ce que vous refaites de la
télé je ne sais pas vous aimeriez
[Musique]
et comme Patrick Sabatier ne revient pas
à la télé forcément il veut pas que ces
concepts reviennent donc c'est fini
c'est mort faut pas chercher c'est pas
dur ou pas Mathieu il faut pas chercher
midi à 14h pourquoi ces émissions
reviennent les jeunes se détournent de
la télévision ils sont sur les
plateformes il regarde la télévision sur
Youtube et cetera donc c'est un public
de plus en plus âgé qui regarde la
télévision et quelle est la phrase qui
est inscrite en gras sur tous les sur
tous les dans les cuisines des personnes
âgées c'est c'était mieux avant donc on
leur donne que des choses qui existaient
dans le temps parce que tu es à côté
d'une personne âgée
je commence à dire c'est normal ça fait
partie de la nostalgie parce qu'on me
fait toujours parler évidemment
mais j'en fais partie sauf que je ne
suis pas nostalgique c'est à dire quoi
vous dire maintenant qu'avant non j'ai
pas dit
que vous savez la télé c'est toujours un
peu de reflet de de la société bon là
maintenant tu as dit un truc qui est pas
mal c'est manque de créativité parce que
moi je trouve très bien qu'on reprenne
des émissions mais je pense qu'à la base
derrière les émissions il y a l'époque
il y a la mentalité il y a plein de
choses on peut pas refaire les émissions
comme elles étaient mais par exemple
ça me plaît pas parce que c'est on met
un truc qui était comme ça avant et on
le remet maintenant mais la vie a
tellement changé
je voudrais tempérer pardon parce que
justement les jeunes ils regardent pas
certes pas la télé sauf quand c'est HPI
ou un truc qui brusquement les FEDER
mais en revanche sur tous les autres sur
tous leurs supports ils regardent des
vieux trucs de Lina il regarde plein de
vieux trucs moi j'ai vu toujours des
gamins qui riait devant des caméras
cachées des frères roulants
allume la télé ils disent encore ah
c'est cool il faut encore la voyante
tout ce qui est bonne aventure avec une
dame qu'elle est en plateau que attends
j'ai quand même vous dire un truc
incroyable c'est pour préparer ce
plateau j'appelle Daniela Lumbroso et
qui sait
c'est triste de France 2 est-ce que tu
peux dire c'est le bateau cette semaine
ah je peux pas je suis en Normandie je
viendrai une semaine je vis tu as vu
l'émission qui reviennent et puis oui
c'est drôle l'anecdote quand même me
racontait elle me dit il y a une semaine
je regarde la télévision avec mes
enfants et il y a ma fille qui m'appelle
qu'elle va t'amener qui maman maman
viens voir il y a un truc génial c'est
quoi c'est les gens ils disent un truc
et il tire un rideau
17 jeudi soir elle regarde elle dit non
mais c'est c'est le jeu de Fontaine
bataille limite c'est génial ça a 20 ans
la gamine pensait n'avait pas vu que
c'est du 4 tiramasteurisé mais avec
Camille pensait que c'était une nouvelle
émission et elle adorait tout comme
Benoît qui lors de la première m'a dit
mais c'est génial cette émission alors
que tu étais pas née
mais c'est génial ça y est ça recommence
ce que vous dites et merci pour vos
compliments et la regarder surtout
nombreux mais le vrai truc c'est que tu
as oublié un truc important c'est pas
qu'on manque de concept c'est que les
concepts dont on parle étaient des bons
concepts et que pardon mais moi je
regarde et j'ai regardé des kilomètres
de la vérité qui compte que j'ai produit
et animé il y a 20 ans franchement ça
tient encore la route en termes de
concept ça paraît tout bête dans mon
émission par exemple il y a beaucoup les
yeux des gens beaucoup les regards et
que on avait un écran qui était en l'air
et tu te retrouvais face too face comme
sur insta ou comme sur FaceTime avec
quelqu'un qui venait de parler et tout
d'un coup il se passait un truc
animateur existait plus etc bah ça c'est
un élément conceptuel d'avoir tout
simplement la vérité qui arrive d'en
haut les yeux qui se lèvent et la caméra
qui peut vraiment fixer les yeux des
gens c'est ça marche encore c'est super
fort et pourquoi tu lances pas alors des
frais on est en train d'en parler tu le
sais très bien je sais pas d'accord
Benoît ah non j'ai dit que j'avais très
bien alors attends Daniel Daniel Daniel
Daniel monsieur bavardée
je suis pas grâce à toi non mais ce que
je voulais dire est-ce que ce que je
voulais dire c'est vrai moi je sais que
les gens les jeunes ils regardent des
extraits de midi-pyre de toujours les
mêmes trucs qui sont passés 20 fois que
Claude François qui arrive pas voilà il
faut que j'improvise pendant 25 minutes
et souvent les jeunes me disent ah mais
pourquoi vous faites pas des émissions
comme comme vous faisiez c'est vrai mais
vous savez pourquoi c'est tout simple
c'est qu'à nos époques excuse-moi tu es
sûrement plus jeune que moi mais bon à
nos époques et bien il y avait de
l'humain il y avait vous êtes les deux à
le dire oui d'accord
si on s'est bien beau les concepts mais
il faut s'intéresser à l'environnement
vous intéresser à la vie des gens pour
savoir ce qui a changé la mentalité qui
a changé
en général manque d'humain de partage de
solidarité de plus d'humain totalement
avec la nostalgie est-elle une bonne
idée à la télé parce que déjà c'est pas
le même sujet ce dont on parle depuis
tout à l'heure ce qui disait Isabelle
est-ce que disait Laurent c'est à dire
que des vieux des vieilles émissions
qu'on revoit ça nous ramène un parfum
une couleur qu'on a aimé etc mais avant
en fait on avait pas assez d'idées donc
on a acheté des formats à l'étranger
aujourd'hui on n'a pas assez d'idées
donc on va repêcher nos vieilles
émissions alors je suis désolé pardon
alors je donne
l'exemple je suis désolé évidemment
parfois il y a des bonnes idées je
rejette pas tout mais par exemple
aujourd'hui si on parle d'une émission
politique je préfère la fraîcheur d'un
face à Baba que du retour de l'heure de
pour ceux qui s'en souviennent de
l'heure de vérité qui a été l'émission
politique de référence pendant des
années moi quand je regarde la famille
en or sur TF1 aujourd'hui c'est à
s'ouvrir les veines tellement ça fout le
bourdon je suis désolé c'est franchement
c'est des formats qui sont passés
embêtante
ça veut dire c'est effectivement il y a
une part de de vrai dans ce que dit
Florian par exemple vos émissions celle
de Cyril c'est un style de l'époque ça
marche super bien je suis pas sûr que
dans 20 ans quelqu'un serait capable de
faire ce que vous faites ce que je veux
dire à Julien moi c'est que Julien
à part Jean-Luc Reichmann c'est tout à
l'époque Reichmann c'est peut-être pas
mes dents c'est peut-être vous qui ça va
oui
son concept j'avais interview Patrick
Sabatier qui m'avait dit avis de
recherche c'est mon idée porte-bonheur
c'est mon idée le jeu de la vérité c'est
mon idée aujourd'hui là aujourd'hui sur
la télé française trouvez-moi une une
émission une à part celle-là peut-être
de une émission qui sont un concept tu
as vu un patron de chaîne tu dis tiens
qu'est-ce que tu en penses on ferait ça
on ferait ça moi je te le dis je suis
producteur tu arrives si tu arrives pas
avec les mecs tu dis ça fait comment en
Angleterre c'est quoi les scores là-bas
ça marche ou pas ça arrive pas avec un
truc qui a déjà fait exactement rien tu
n'as rien
erreur je pense que c'est l'erreur de de
ceux qui font la télé très haut niveau
c'est que l'humain a complètement
disparu et il pense que marketing parce
que c'est l'époque qui est comme ça
Daniel quand on parle d'humain quand on
parle d'humain je veux aussi vous dire
un truc moi je vois les animateurs
aujourd'hui ils font de jeu comme toi 5
6 jeux dans la journée ils voient 90
candidats c'est très panaguy qui leur
ami mais je crois que Nagui il comprend
les prénoms ils prenons ici il dit
bonjour à personne il se casse
par jour est-ce que tu connais cette
candidats non pas du tout par contre
pour savoir ce que j'allais ce que
j'allais tirer deux tu vois qui me
plaisait plus qui était plus payant sur
en terme de télévision tu vois d'accord
je voudrais je suis d'accord avec toi
mais là sur la télé pas du tout parce
que quand on regarde la télé alors moi
j'adore l'histoire de la télé quand on
regarde la télé à partir des années 60
qui a eu une créativité un nombre
d'émissions incroyable ont été créé et
Louvain me disait un jour il avait
raison passez une certaine date c'est un
reboutiquage et c'est les moyens
techniques qui font la différence mais
les idées elles ont tout été donné
quasiment déjà avant les années 70 et
quand on regarde l'histoire de la télé
ressortir là en ce moment sont dans les
cartons justement l'émission de Foucault
c'était quoi c'était pardon sacrée
soirée on commence à en parler le
problème de Louvain qui est producteur
pardon quand on lui en parle vous dit
c'est pas le premier mission c'est qu'on
a plus de stars et qu'aujourd'hui
c'était un événement avant d'aller sur
la Place Rouge avec Rika Zaraï bon
maintenant tu l'amènes là les momies
j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
premier combat à l'époque quand il est
parti de ces 8 il devait aller chez M6
pour refaire la Star Academy mais
Nicolas taverno n'avait pas dit non pour
mettre au moins 500 000 à 1 million
d'euros par prime il n'était pas
d'accord mais moi ce qui me battait
de parler de voir que je vois un mec
comme Benoît qui est un mot comme il a
32 ans ce qui préfère à la télévision ce
sont les émissions que moi je regardais
quand j'étais plus jeune que lui c'est
là où je me dis qu'est-ce qui n'a pas
fonction qu'est-ce qu'on a pas super
alors vas-y Sophie Jean-Michel a raison
quand il dit que les enfants ne
regardent plus la télévision les enfants
ils ont 20 16 et 13 il regarde plus la
télévision il regarde pas non plus
pardonnez-moi Daniel Gilbert mais ni non
plus les images de Lina ils sont sur
Call of Duty donc non mais moi je vous
ai pas parlé
tous les invités ou
alors j'ai une question très importante
à vous poser je pose une question quand
j'ai interviewé encore une fois au
téléphone mon ami d'ailleurs brozo elle
m'a sorti une phrase je pense qu'il faut
en faire un débat ici tu m'appelles pas
moi
les textos
non alors je vais vous appeler très
intéressantes à me dire reconnaissez que
tous les hommes qui reviennent fontaines
bataille de Chavanne Laga tous tous sont
les hommes il y a pas une femme qui
reviennent ça c'est un vrai sujet alors
est-ce que c'est parce que les femmes
n'incarnaient pas des concepts où est-ce
que parce que quand on vieillit qu'on
ait une femme on ne revient pas les
femmes ne reviennent pas pourquoi j'en
sais mais moi c'était un concept enfin
qui n'était pas un concept et c'était
une femme qui voudrait revenir j'étais
sept ans non j'ai pas revenir mais je
reviens en Belgique alors bon c'est vrai
c'est un vrai sucette
est-ce que ça marche en audience c'est
ça
on aurait été deux femmes parce qu'elle
et moi ça aurait j'espère aussi bien
marché et on serait quand même inventé
aujourd'hui l'audience était très forte
on réessaye aujourd'hui ce que tu dis
puisqu'il est la seule qu'ils ont
ressorti c'est c'est fait flamand pour
Star à domicile ça n'a pas marché non ça
n'a pas marché et ça n'a pas marché
aussi parce qu'elle a pas voulu jouer le
jeu comme elle est un peu vieilli bah
contrairement à vous plutôt que de faire
le truc elle a elle a voulu faire un
truc un peu un peu assis un grand chat
elle était là comme ça avec un truc ici
il faut faire une chose c'est qu'un un
vieux c'est un c'est sûr mais un jeune
c'est peut-être un futur vieux
je suis pas choqué c'est très bien
en Suisse du même genre qui sont venus
et bien oui
je terminerai par cette phrase bien sûr
c'est terminé
le vieux connait le chemin la semaine
prochaine merci beaucoup